You weren't like the Segway,
but I'm going to go for it anyway.
One of the things that the trump
campaign did was exactly that.
He connected with hearts.
He managed to get emotion on the
campaign trail.
I'm sure you were at the rallies.
I was at the rallies.
They were noisier and they were more
passionate than any other one that I
attended and I did a lot.
So the question is,
if the left wants to get back into the
business of winning,
does it have to find an emotional
message of politics?
Does that sound like the right way or do
you,
or would you consider that to be a sort
of a populous trap?
How would you.
No,
I think it's a very important insights.
One that I share.
I'm a big believer that people actually
don't listen through their ears.
They listen through their stomachs,
and if you as a leader or reporter
connect to someone on a gut level,
their usual attitude is don't bother me
with the details,
and if you don't connect with them on a
gut level,
you can't show them enough details.
Could I see that?
Third Point you made,
just one more time.
And so what was Hillary Clinton's most
off quoted line in this campaign?
Visit my website,
www dot hillary clinton.
It wasn't connecting at the gauntlet was
visit my website and um,
and I was making this point a friendly
on results.
Here is a brilliant writer and Leon
wieseltier wants describe Utok Rabine
the Israeli prime minister as a bastard
for peace.
Okay.
And I think that's what the left needs
in America.
They need a,
a,
someone who can connect with people on a
gut level,
but take them in a progressive direction
forward not where trump wants to take
them,
which I believe is to a dark corner
backward.
And that's what the left needs.
Obama had some of that.
I'm not all of it.
Bill Clinton had some of that.
Um,
but,
uh,
I don't see anyone on the national stage
in America today who really has that.